[Music]
it was recently announced that the us
theatrical release of ant-man and wasp
quantomania will be postponed to
february 17 2023 it thus swamps the
release slot with the captain marvel
sequel the marvels the early premiere is
all the more reason to take a quick look
at the 31st film in the mcu and check
out the cast the script and everything
in between we have dealt with all these
questions and will answer them for you
in this video so stay tuned
unfortunately it is not really known yet
as to what time period the plot is set
it is certain though that the story will
take place after end game since the
older version of cassie is supposed to
play a big role in the movie it is also
possible that quite some time has passed
since endgame and that the relationship
between scott and hope has developed
further like many of the avengers
ant-man will surely have taken some time
off after the hardships of battling
thanos chronologically then the movie
can probably be put between black
panther wakanda forever and guardians of
the galaxy vol 3. however we assume that
the plots do not affect each other the
disney plus series loki has greater
significance in this respect everyone
who has not seen it yet should do so
before watching quantum mania we will
explain why later also as in many of our
other videos there is an imminent risk
of spoilers
in the meantime quite a bit is already
known about the cast which is mainly due
to the fact that filming is quite
advanced at the time of making this
video there are some new faces including
a surprise or two in addition there will
be someone returning which fans
certainly were not expecting anymore so
we are even more excited to see how the
writers plan to incorporate him back
into this story
everyone was surely aware that there
would be no major changes to the
characters of ant-man and the wasp of
course paul radd and evangeline lilly
will once again play the title
characters scott lang and hope thundine
whether and how their suits will be
modified in the third part we do not
know so far neither are there any
changes to hope's parents dr henry hank
pym and jen van dyne are also part of
the team and will be again played by
michael douglas and michelle pfeiffer
the first new cast member is scott's
daughter cassie this character will now
already be played by a third actress in
parts one and two the young cassie was
portrayed by abby ryder fortune in end
game she got the first recast where
she's embodied by emma fuhrman this is
mainly due to the fact that she survived
the snap and thus aged by 5 years
however it is now clear that a new
actress has been hired for quantomania
2. this time it is catherine newton who
will play the role of ant-man's daughter
what is controversial here is that
furman was not even informed about the
recasting in advance
he was first introduced in the series
loki though not really as a villain
nevertheless fans know that he's a
manifest character the talk here is
about kang the conqueror whose real name
is nathaniel richards in the marvel
universe he's related to reed richards
aka mr fantastic the head of the
fantastic four and at least in some
universes the smartest person on earth
so this could be another step in slowly
but surely incorporating the fantastic
four into the mcu kang is played here as
in loki by jonathan magers
already in the first ant-man film main
character scott lang met the villain
darren cross also known as yellowjacket
in the end ant-man was finally able to
defeat his opponent by manipulating his
suit and thus seemingly crushing him in
the past the theory that cross could
have survived the entire event came up
more often not least because director
peyton reid himself spoke of cross
possibility just being trapped in the
quantum realm that's not a definite
announcement yet of course but combined
with an image released by evangeline
lilly things are slowly but surely
starting to take on a clear shape the
wasp actress put the name of
yellowjacket actor corey stuller
hashtags and deleted the picture again
shortly after which is a pretty clear
sign as we think
another celebrity joining the movie is
bill murray murray is probably one of
the most popular actors in hollywood it
is not known yet which part he will play
and the actor himself was not allowed to
reveal anything up to now when asked by
a reporter what his superpowers are he
replied my superpower is that i'm a bad
guy ant-man could therefore have to deal
with the multitude of antagonists rumor
has it that murray could take on the
role of crylar appropriately enough he's
up to mischief on the quantum realm
it was clear fairly quickly that a third
ant-man film would be made the first two
parts together grossed more than one
billion us dollars peyton reed was soon
brought in again as director having
already taken the reigns in the first
two movies jeff loveness who has already
written episodes for rick and morty was
selected as the screenwriter the new
film seems to have a lot of humor to
offer two years after the sequel was
confirmed filming began at pinewood
studios in nearby london as with the
mandalorian the movie will be shot using
stagecraft technology this involves
previously created backgrounds being
projected onto large led video walls on
the film set at the end of november 2021
filming of the last scene was completed
which was much faster than anticipated
in fact filming was not expected to end
until the beginning of 2022 at the
earliest which is why the movie release
has now been rescheduled ahead of time
to february 2023
unfortunately nothing is known about the
plot at this point so we can only
speculate as to how this story might
continue the main question here is how
kang could make an appearance does he
come from the future the past or is it
even the version of kang that lives on
earth at this time it would also be
feasible that he comes to earth through
the quantum realm or maybe he needs the
perhaps unintended help of cryler and
jello jacket to what degree kang is
aware of himself or his other versions
also remains to be seen maybe he's not
introduced as a villain at all but is
still or even permanently on the good
side as nathaniel richards this would be
especially conceivable if you want to
bring up kang as the next big enemy of
the new avengers it also seems to be
coming into fashion in the mcu right now
to turn former heroes into villains in
any case he seems a bit too powerful as
the sole antagonist for ant-man another
storyline we are looking forward to is
that of cassie lang for us the recasting
can mean two things first that scott's
time in the ant-man suit is slowly but
surely coming to an end and that his
daughter will take over as superhero
stature at least she would fit in well
with the rest of the young avengers in
the comics she lives with her father at
the avengers headquarters where without
the knowledge of the other members she
secretly injects herself with pym
particles by doing so she alters her
genes and develops superpowers like her
father she can't shrink or grow taller
but without the suit however as we said
at the beginning there are only
assumptions about what direction the
plot might take anyway it should not
take much longer until the first trailer
will be released then we will surely
know more about scott hope and cassie
that was our preview of ant-man and the
wasp quantomania even though not much is
known so far we were hopefully still
able to give you a good overview what do
you think the plot might look like let
us know in the comments and if you
enjoyed the video don't forget to give
it a thumbs up see you next time
[Music]
you